over five
should never bad dejeuner traverser
mondo
[Music]
bonsoir je m'appelle Shivangi em I'm the
leader of the truck program here Tesla
and it's my great pleasure to welcome
you here in Los Angeles
[Applause]
all of you all of you I've played a very
important role in making this event
possible and ensuring the success of
Tesla many of you here have given lots
of referrals for their cells thank you
very much
many of you over there have helped us on
the trek program have given us feedback
and begin us a lot of advice and have
placed a lot of reservations for the
truck so thank you very much for your
support and finally I want to thank all
of our employees here in Los Angeles in
the Bay Area and at the gigafactory
for all the hard work for something
we make a lot of sacrifices but I think
you will agree with me that it's worth
it when you see those beautiful products
I'm personally personally very
passionate about trucks I've been lucky
to work in that industry for a long time
and I'm proud to say that we have the
best trucks ever are you ready to see
them bring them on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but we're gonna put again the trucks the
moment goes trucks the moment alright
alright welcome welcome welcome to the
to the welcome to the Tesla semi truck
event I hope you like what you see I'm
going to tell you about everything that
this this truck can do it blows my mind
I think it'll blow yours starting with
performance so ever an acronym we came
up with
that I think really really describes
performance well
so SEC technical term but let's show you
what that means in in acceleration so
one thing that care about Tesla is we
were looking about performance we want
we want a vehicle that feels incredible
that accelerates like nothing else let's
show what the truck what it's like to be
in a Tesla truck this is real time
[Applause]
okay so that's but the Tesla the Tesla
semi on will go zero to 60 in five
seconds that that's by itself or with a
trailer now at eighty thousand pounds
max gross vehicle weight but that's the
most amount of weight you can carry on a
US Highway this is the real-time
acceleration
otezla semi that on the left the thing
that looks like it's not moving is a
diesel truck
give it a moment I sorry to bore you I
apologize
boring I know especially it'll get there
alright
even with 80,000 pounds pulling max
gross getting 60 miles an hour in 20
seconds that's what it can do
now what about up a hill okay the the
best diesel trucks can only do 45 miles
an hour up a five percent grade Tesla
Sam I can do 65 miles an hour for 5%
grade that's 65 miles an hour continuous
at max gross
but what this means is that if you've
got if you're pulling a load over the
Rockies or some mountainous terrain up a
hill you're earning per mile you're
earning fifty percent more per mile than
you are in a diesel truck that's a
gigantic difference so now one of the
biggest questions we've been asked about
electric trucks is well how far can they
go because well let's find out so 500
mile range
but
[Applause]
but what is a 500 mile range mean and by
the way it's 500 miles at maximum weight
at highway speed suturing like 60 miles
an hour that's a worst-case scenario but
what it means is that to speak because
the vast majority of routes because the
vast majority aren't are under 250 miles
it means that you can go to your
destination and back even if that your
destination has no charging you can you
can go there and back go there at home
with without recharging so you could you
could deliver a load out to the middle
of nowhere and come back
[Applause]
now how do we achieve this one of the
ways we do this is we design the Tesla
truck to be like a bullet so whereas a
normal diesel truck is designed more
like a barn wall this is a bullet you
can see this in the drag coefficient so
the Tesla semi has a point three six
drag refers to the wave this is a really
good number as by way of comparison of a
bugatti chiron which is a 2
million-dollar supercar has a point
three eight drag coefficient this is got
a better drag coefficient than a
supercar and by the way we yeah all the
way you can see that in the design the
weather we achieve that is with the bold
shaped nose we also have side flaps that
map to the whatever trail you're pulling
well it's a new trailer of old trailer
but the side flaps will map to whatever
trail you're pulling and close the gap
so this this makes a huge difference to
the drag coefficient the the bottom of
the truck is also completely flat so air
can flow straight through these are
things that you don't see on any other
trucks and it gives us incredible
highway range or the key factors we also
have four independent motors aren't to
visit the motor on each of the rear
wheels and an independent front
suspension so it's incredibly
comfortable to to drive this truck yeah
[Applause]
and then we just or we're interesting we
created a pickup truck version of the
Tesla semi it's a pickup truck that can
carry a pickup truck
[Applause]
by the way this is you can legally drive
that and it shouldn't be legal but you
will actually be able to legally drive
that with a normal driver's license
it's kind of wrong but no I get now I'll
go to the driver experience what does it
feel like to drive this truck it's
amazing because this truck has no beers
it's there's no you're not constantly
shifting gears it has one one gear so
it's it's smooth it's like driving it's
like driving a Tesla it's as though
you're driving a Model S or model act so
model 3 it's just big it's so really
it's super easy to drive and it feels
incredibly responsive unlike any truck
that you've ever driven um and and the
point of view that you have is also
incredible we put the driver in the
center so the driver is actually in the
center of the truck you're positioned
like you're in a race car you have
complete visibility of the road and all
the surroundings
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a beautiful spacious interior you
can stand up inside
it's got redundant screens and it's it
just feels incredible drivers it's one
of the best feelings it's it's so it's
incomparably better than another than
any other truck on the road you really
have to drive it to understand just how
good that feels like I can drive this
thing and I have no idea how to drive a
semi so take a few look take three more
shots of the interior just gives you a
sense by the way will sound like
[Music]
also there's a little there's a little
trunk in the front all right
let's throw it in there well it's
compared to I don't want to hurt your
eyes but that's what a diesel truck
looks like today it's a clutter of third
party devices it's very difficult to use
it requires integration installation
these things don't talk to each other
it's it's a it's a pain in the neck it
has significant app so giving it add-on
costs whereas the Tesla semi all this is
included it's included in every in every
truck everything just works the moment
you get the truck it's got everything
and it'll seamlessly integrate with with
all the fleet systems the things that
are really important to the trucking
industry so what about you know fueling
today with your feeling a diesel truck
you've got fumes wells toxic environment
prices changed all the time and what a
lot of people don't realize is it
actually it takes up to 15 minutes or
more to actually fill up a truck get to
sit there for 15 minutes well the tank
gets built as compared to charging a
Tesla truck you can charge at your arts
and or destination so while you're
unloading your cargo you can charge
[Music]
[Applause]
so the reason the reason the reason 400
miles is important is because you have
you you have to trach take a break
eventually
so so if you drive for if you drive for
5 or 6 hours which is a that's about as
much as you want to be driving
continuously you have to stop for
bathroom break good get a bite to eat
in fact you're legally required to stop
for 30 minutes so but you if 400 miles
is like 6 plus a 6 to 7 hours of driving
which means that what this means in
practice is that by the time you are
you're done with your break that the
truck is ready to go you will not be
waiting for your truck to charge it's a
big deal
[Applause]
and because of the Tesla mega charges
that will be installing well that just
like we've got super charges installed
worldwide if you've seen the super
charge of math it started off was just a
few super with just a few charges in
California now we have super charges I
don't know throughout the world you be
able to go anywhere in with a Tesla
consumer vehicle the same will be true
of the Tesla semi you'll be able to
travel area anywhere in the world on the
Tesla mega charger Network and and that
means we can guarantee the electricity
rates because these will be solar
powered mega charges that charge to
Tesla power pad is 24/7 guaranteed low
electricity
[Applause]
and because this is mega charge is a
solar-powered your truck is running on
sunlight okay what about safety
now when I say safety I'm talking about
the the driver safety I'm also talking
about other cars on the road and Tory
have pedestrians safety for everyone if
you've got 80,000 pounds moving at 60
miles an hour that's it's a very
dangerous thing every truck we sell will
have enhanced autopilot as standard okay
[Applause]
but the truck will automatically brake
alright good yeah you can read it too or
it'll automatically break but it will
actually automatically Lane keep as well
so even if even if even if you're in the
truck and you have a medical emergency
the truck will stay in lane and
gradually come to a halt and put on the
Emergencies if it doesn't hear a
response from you will actually call
emergency services and get an ambulance
it's gonna take care of you is going to
take care of other cars you can take
care of pedestrians this is a massive
increase in safety
[Applause]
a few other things about safety it's go
with that central position you're in a
very safe position even if you were to
collide with with another semi you have
a low center of gravity that gives you
really good handling means the
probability of a rollover is massively
reduced because the battery pack is in
the floor pan and and rollover risk is
reduced and perhaps most importantly
jackknifing is is usually the worst
nightmare of a trucker how do you stop
your vehicle from from jackknifing and
if you're in difficult conditions the
truck will automatically stop
jackknifing because it's got independent
motors on each wheel and it'll
dynamically adjust the torque on each
wheel so that Jeff jackknifing is
impossible
[Applause]
your worst nightmare is gone with this
truck gone never have to worry about it
[Applause]
this miserable job reliability
reliability is incredibly important at
the truck is is your life it's your
business truck breaks down you
disappointing your customers it's a it's
a horrible day to be a horrible week it
could break down the middle of nowhere
it's the safety issues reliability is
incredibly important we're putting
massive attention it's make this truck
incredibly reliable and that's why we
are guaranteeing that this truck will
not break down for a million miles
[Applause]
we're guaranteeing it won't break down
for a million miles because it has four
independent motors you can lose two of
those four motors and the truck will
still keep going in fact even if you
only have two of the four motors active
it'll still be a diesel truck it's not
fair really
so then what it has a few other benefits
as well
brakes brakes are a big deal for trucks
you got to stop 80,000 pounds it's not
easy that's a lot of break for a lot of
brake wear but because the with an
electric motor you can turn the breaks
into generators so every time you break
that kinetic energy of braking goes
right straight back into the battery
pack instead of heat instead of wearing
down a brake pad it's the brake pads
basically last forever but you'd ever
need to replace brake pads ever ever so
yeah no Brad no brake pad changes ever
never worry about transmission there's
no transmission transmission can't break
there are no emissions no scrubbers and
their differentials and and this is the
feature I like best thermonuclear
explosions improve class
[Applause]
close means close so standard glass now
why is this important cuz baby look
nothing survived to nuclear explosion
that's incredible
so the actually what's important here is
by nuclear survives a nuclear explosion
or you get a full refund for refund the
the reason this is important is because
truck windshields are huge and they
crack about once a year and if the truck
windshield is cracked you're not allowed
to drive it so it actually it's truck
offroad if you have a pract windshield
and that and that means lost driving you
disappointed customers it's a terrible
it's a terrible day and you if you're
stuck in a middle of nowhere take ages
to get out to get a new windshield so
actually this this this detail this
detail matters a lot to to someone who
really understands trucking it's it's
small but very important then we have in
terms of connectivity to your truck
understanding what's going on we have
the Tesla app that gives you full
information about your truck this is
sort of normal it's like we take it for
granted with if you've got a Model S or
more leches like that but this is not
normal actually for trucks you have full
access to all your truck information you
got remote diagnostics you can you can
see what's going on preventive
maintenance the truck will actually
anticipate when it needs to be made when
it needs maintenance and and inform you
ahead of time and it connects with the
fleet so if you've got to try to manage
a fleet of thousands of trucks it's also
incredibly important all this data is
coming in you know exactly what's going
on it's going to really help you manage
your trucking now having said all this
you're probably wondering how much is it
going to cost
because Tesla stuff is expensive
but we realize that trucking the
economics of trucking matter
tremendously if if you have a truck if
your classroom while is too high it
doesn't make economic sense you can't
make it work
so we've really thought about slide and
when you take everything into account
take the least cost the insurance cost
maintenance all of the factors the fully
accounted for true cost of trucking a
diesel truck will be 20% more expensive
than then it says a semi per mile on
retail this is from day one it from day
one having a Tesla semi will beat a
diesel truck on economics day one and
this is at this is a worst-case scenario
so it gets better than this this is the
this is the work this is worst-case in
our comparison this is taking max
vehicle gross it's going at sixty miles
an hour and it's assuming to $50
gasoline price we're guaranteeing a
seven cent kilowatt wholesale price what
I'm clear about that this is real these
are real numbers and it only gets better
than this
this is a worst case scenario
now one truck one otezla truck
considered by itself beats other diesel
trucks but what if you have a convoy so
what if you have trucks two trucks
following so your country you're more
like a train train driver in fact but
the convoy technology the tracking
technology this is something that we
have confident we could do today ten
times safer than a human driver so this
is I wanna be clear this is something we
can do now
and work that plane they go now if you
look at the economics of a truck convoy
it gets way better now a diesel truck is
twice as expensive as it has a semi the
business so it's what this means is it's
not just economic suicide to use one
diesel truck its economic suicide for
rail this beats rail
[Applause]
so and that's that's I think really
quite quite profound we're confident
that this is a product that is better in
every way from a future standpoint that
wins on economics against diesel trucks
in a worst case scenario and that
defeats rail in a convoy scenario and
production begins 2019 so if you order
now get part the truck in two years
[Applause]
right so that's the the Tesla but Tesla
Sam I hope you guys enjoyed what you saw
our guys take away thank you Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so turns out there was some cargo in the
truck
there's some cargo in the truck we threw
it bring it out
we started Tesla we start Tesla with a
sports car Tesla Roadster that's that
that baby got us going it's it's the it
was the foundation the whole company was
- Tesla Roadster a few have asked us for
a long time when are you gonna make a
new roadster we are making it now
[Applause]
and you know this energy watch
Spaceballs movie but this there's only
thing there's only one thing that's
beyond ludicrous which is plaid
[Music]
so that the Tesla but the new Tesla
Roadster will be the fastest car
production car ever made
period
[Applause]
and this is the base this is the base
model okay this is good base model we're
going to talk about things beyond base
maybe next year sometime this is the
base model base model will do 0 to 60 in
1.9 seconds okay
it'll bet if that is the fastest this is
we the first time that any car has
broken 2 seconds at 0-60 it'll be it'll
be the fastest to a hundred miles an
hour 4.2 seconds to 100 miles an hour
[Music]
beep absolute passion on that jet over
there it'll do the quarter-mile in eight
point nine seconds this will be the
first time that any car has broke in
nine seconds any production cars broke
in nine seconds and a quarter-mile these
are these are all these are all world
records okay this is what we're
achieving in the prototype I would say
what the actual top speed is but it's
above 250 miles an hour
the range this is going to have a 200
kilowatt hour battery pack
[Applause]
so 606 this is these number sound not
even for their real 600 620 mile range
that's not a thousand kilometer range
this be the first time in electric
vehicle brakes a thousand kilometres a
production electric vehicle will travel
more than a thousand kilometres and
single charts at highway speed
[Applause]
but you'll be able to travel from LA to
San Cisco and back at highway speed
without recharging the point of doing
this is to just give the hard-core
smackdown to gasoline cars
[Applause]
drive driving a gasoline sports car is
gonna feel like a steam engine with a
side of quiche this thing will have
three motors so it's all-wheel drive one
motor in the front turn two on the rear
I'll do torque steering I said turning
coming out load our battery pack ten
thousand Newton meters of torque if you
know what that means it's stupid it's
also a four-seater yeah so it's a two
plus two two plus two okay
you can't put giant people in the in the
rear seat but you will to put okay a
giant person is squashed or a small
small person fit in the bed so but it's
a four-seater it's not like if this is
four seats
it's convertible so it's a Ruvo roof
it's and it has tons of storage so you
like actually travel somewhere bring
bring luggage bring whatever you want
and have plenty of storage carry for
people like it's a real car it's not
just crammed in so it has all that
functionality with four seats
[Applause]
and available expected this to be
available in 2020
so yeah exactly so would you like to
come up would you like to come up and
going up come on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]